I want to keep talking about trade for
now though we've been talking a ton
about this trade fiasco that's been
caused by Donald Trump and it's actually
a problem with many of our allies but
right now it's acutely a problem with
Canada and most of our conversations are
either about trade sort of generally
we've talked about the sources of the
tariffs that actually exists between the
United States and Canada some of the
Canadian tariffs on on US products are a
response to either US tariffs or US
subsidies as I spoke about with the
dairy industry we've talked about the
trade balance that something Donald
Trump also really likes to talk about
we've also explored Donald Trump's
general incompetence on trade but one
thing we haven't talked about yet is
another way in which the entire thing
can blow up in Donald Trump's pee face
which it's likely to do and that's
called boycotts a Canadian boycott of
both American products and of traveling
to the United States has started slowly
but especially over the last ten to
fourteen days is building more and more
there's another movement that is focused
specifically on encouraging a Canadian
's
not to travel to the United States to
cancel their planned travel to the
United States and many Canadians are
actually doing it and there are Canadian
websites that provide information to
Canadians about whether products are
made in the United States or not so that
Canadians can if they want to opt for
the non American products and when I
tell you about this I know that I'm
gonna get right-wing nuts
emailing me saying David go back to
Argentina or Israel or wherever it is
you're from and stop taking pleasure in
the boycotting of American businesses
and I'm not reporting it to you because
I'm taking pleasure in it I'm reporting
it to you because it pains me and I want
to stop it we we need to have a total
stop to the ruining of our ji'er
geopolitical relationships by Donald
Trump this isn't fun and games right
jobs depend on what Trump tweets and his
harebrained ideas people's livelihoods
depend on the actions of the President
and a
to break it to you but it's not just
Canadian tourists that are bailing on
traveling to the United States we told
you in January of 2018 about travel data
from 2017 to the United States and a lot
of countries are drastically reducing
their travel to the United States the
u.s. can manage without it's not going
to end the United in United States
economy but jobs are going to be lost
and it won't be good for the economy the
data for 2017 was that 4.6 billion
dollars and about 40,000 jobs were lost
as a result of other countries citizens
reducing their tourism to the United
States much of that attributed of course
to the presidency of Donald Trump and I
hate the boycotts the boycotts are bad
for friends of mine who own businesses
they're bad for people I don't even know
I mean can you imagine I can actually
empathize with people that I don't even
know and it's bad for them but this
could be an effective way to state to
take a stand if people do it we know
that bookings in Trump's hotels even
Trump branded hotels not owned by Trump
but where the name is licensed to Trump
have been taking a hit I have family
very anecdotally in Argentina that is
specifically saying you know we usually
go to the US every two or three years
we're due for that but we're not gonna
go we're gonna go elsewhere because we
simply don't want to go when Donald
Trump is President of the United States
if you're wondering whether Trump even
cares I kind of doubt it I kind of doubt
it and it's yet another way in which he
said he was gonna look out for the
little guy he said he was gonna look out
for the middle man know the middle class
but it's just not happening and so far
it doesn't actually seem like his
supporters are punishing him for it and
that's the scariest thing in the context
of the upcoming midterm elections and
I'm gonna talk about that a little bit
later in the program
join the discussion with more than 6,000
of our viewers and listeners on our
subreddit trade a big topic of
discussion there as well as Paul
Manafort going to jail and lots of the
other things we discussed on today's
show david pakman.com slash re d di t is
where you find the sub
read quick break new-and-improved
shorter breaks on the David Pakman show
coming up next today's program sponsored
in part by movement movement don't just
make great watches they also make great
sunglasses and have just released a
bunch of new styles to get you ready for
the warm weather I've talked about the
problems I've had with sunglasses namely
losing really expensive sunglasses and
then feeling like I was completely
ripped off our friends at movement felt
the same way so they made quality trendy
sunglasses at a fair price they're not
made from cheap plastic they're actually
made from acetate you can get him
polarized they start at 70 bucks many
styles to choose from I went with the
aviator style when I went on my road
trip from Los Angeles California to San
Francisco California a few weeks ago and
I only sat on them twice and they
completely resisted my full weight and
that was a really really great thing you
can find your perfect pair and get 15%
off today with free shipping and free
returns at MVM t.com slash Pakman you
remember movement for how they
revolutionized the watch industry I'm
still wearing my MVM tea watch you can
now check out their sunglasses at M VMT
dot-com slash Pakman join the movement